I'm curious as your thoughts on Ukraine
as it pertains to the military
industrial complex
well it's amazing how people have no
idea what's going on in Ukraine but
what's worse is they have no idea that
they have no idea what's going on in
Ukraine what's going on in Ukraine is a
proxy war that we've been planning for
years and years to put an economic hurt
on Russia and we're we've always feared
was Russia coming together with Germany
Germany has their technology and they
have their capital and we were always
afraid of Germany's technology and
capital coming together with Russia's uh
Manpower and natural resources so there
they are they come together we
immediately go into action we overthrow
the Ukrainian government because all the
pipelines go through Ukraine we install
a puppet regime and then they start
bombing the donbass which is the eastern
part the russian-speaking part of
Ukraine they bombed it for eight years
straight but they had a peace agreement
called the Minsk Accords That was
supposed to stop it they'd never they
never abided by it that was in 2015 that
the Minsk Accords why don't they ever
abide by that nobody ever so when when
Corporate America media tells the story
about Ukraine they start at Putin's
invasion they don't start with the coup
that the CIA and the right-wing Nazis in
Ukraine pulled off to overthrow a
democratically elected president of
Ukraine and then the people who were the
Russian speakers in the eastern part of
Ukraine didn't want to go along with the
crude government so they didn't want so
that's when Ukraine starts bombing the
hell out of them and so they they killed
16 000 people with so they never talk
about this in the corporate media so and
also Ukraine was going to join NATO
they've been threatening to join NATO
now that's a big deal and everybody's
known for decades that if that happened
that would trigger Putin or Russia to do
something everybody from Chomsky to
Henry Kissinger has said that this is a
this is a political reality this isn't
about who's right or wrong but if we
keep expanding NATO which NATO is no
longer a defensive organization it's
there it's it's com it's it's an
aggressive organization which is being
proven in Ukraine right now and so when
we let Germany uh unify they made a
promise to the Russians that we wouldn't
expand NATO they've expanded NATO like
crazy all the way up to their border now
with Ukraine and so that is triggering
we wouldn't let uh Mexico join a a
military pact with China right and then
China starts putting bases in Mexico we
wouldn't let that happen yeah so that's
what we're that's what we're doing in
Ukraine plus a lot of other things and
this is about so we can sell liquefied
natural gas among other things to Europe
Russia provided 40 percent of the of the
energy to Europe before the Ukraine war
and now the United States wants part of
that and that's what this is all about
that so we can sell more and we are
we're right now selling more liquefied
natural gas to Europe and we also that's
why we blew up the Nordstrom pipeline
which nobody will cover and we blew we
blew it up at and they're bragging about
what a great opportunity this is of
course we did that and why Germany will
go along with this you know Merkel
wouldn't go along with that she pushed
on and she built the Nordstrom pipelines
but now whoever their their their
political class are just puppets and
that's what Putin keeps saying why is
Europe going along with the imperialism
of the United States and NATO which is
exactly what this is so people don't
know that's what this is they think that
all of a sudden Putin woke up one night
and decided to one morning he decided to
invade Ukraine and be a jerk and that's
not what's happening in fact he's the
one who's been pushing for peace talks
and there was a peace agreement in March
NATO sabotaged it because they don't
want a peace agreement they want to put
an economic hurt on Russia and they
don't care how many ukrainians get
slaughtered to do it the ukrainians are
just cannon fodder for an economic War
pushed by the west and NATO you're
familiar with the cutter turkey pipeline
yeah yes that's what the Syrian war is
about it's all interconnected and I
always I always phrase it this way
because you know I'm the milk toast
Spencer guy I'll say you know the United
States wanted to build a pipeline
through Syria through turkey into Europe
to offset the gas prom Natural Gas
Monopoly and then Syria said no our Ally
Russia would not appreciate it if we
allowed you to compete with them and it
would hurt their you know hurt them
economically so Syria Russia Iran they
wanted to build an alternate pipeline
that would tap the same gas field and
send it up through Iraq and turkey into
Ukraine into Europe which would give
Russia more control and then I guess the
United States just got really lucky
somehow Syria fell into Civil War and of
course we opposed Bashar al-assad
because of all the awful things he did
and remember baby Arab that was the Arab
Spring oh yeah yeah sorry yeah grab the
mic yeah uh so I mean look I don't trust
it under under Obama Isis is expanding
rapidly and we were funding them in
Syria you know that well it's it's
killed the bath party and created them
it's it's air quote funding right we we
see these guys driving around in this
truck it wasn't Isis or some other group
and it's like a truck from Detroit with
some guy's phone number on it how are
they getting this equipment yes the
United States wanted Assad out accused
them of all the worst things in the
world and it's because we wanted to
offset gas problems natural gas control
it's not an absolute Monopoly but it's a
large control over it then nordstream 2
gets built strengthening their
distribution into Europe and then it
blows up and the West goes Russia did it
I'm like oh yeah Russia blew up their
own gas pipeline that makes sense they
could have just turned off the gas
exactly
we're turning off our gas that's so none
of this stuff makes fun and that's why
Russia gate never made sense right not a
they you know even though crowdstrike
anyway it gets into the weeds well now
now they're they're saying that uh a lot
of the stuff that pissed off Putin
happened under Trump as if to imply the
war is his fault and it's like no no no
no if that was true Putin would have
taken action during the Trump years but
he didn't to support your claim that
NATO is an offensive pact because it was
supposed to be a defensive pact any
country that gets invaded all the other
ones will defend but it's like a tower
rush if you've ever played Starcraft or
Warcraft where you go as close to their
base as you can and then you start to
build defensive Towers all around their
base so if they try and leave their base
they get attacked by your defensive
Towers so that's what we've done is
we've created a an area of defensive
outposts all around their land what what
I think is happening is that the
Russians after the Soviet Union fell uh
they were the oligarchs split it up so
that the Russia didn't have access to
the Black Sea they didn't want them to
have Mediterranean access because it was
too they didn't want to be a global
hegemon economically and now Putin's
trying take Sebastopol Crimea through
annexation and force he wants the
Eastern Don bass I don't know why it's
not more plaintive and I like and I
could see even even like something where
resilience comes out as a Superhero
fighting peace like he could be the guy
that does it so the irony is that
zielinski ran on a peace platform right
he was he was going to bring peace to
Ukraine and he was going to join
everybody together again he was good he
was a uniter and then my theory of what
happened was that the reason why he did
the exact opposite right he's banned all
opposition media he's banned opposition
political all that stuff he's done
horrible stuff he's he's become the
worst kind of dictator but why would he
do that I think it was because NATO he
knows that if he goes against NATO that
they will kill him and so will the right
wing in his country which are the azov
Battalion Nazis uh those people love it
I mean you've I watch videos of these
guys talking about how they love
fighting and killing and that these guys
are the real deal Nazis and they're you
know I'm not saying that their majority
of people in Ukraine are Nazis I'm
saying a big controlling factor of their
military and their politics are
right-wing Nazis and that's what's going
on over there and people don't know it
so they they would threaten to kill you
of zelinski and that's why zielinski's
doing all this crazy stuff because he's
got no option what else is he going to
do so he became a good boy meaning that
he's going along now he's going to cut
up his country and give it to Blackrock
and all those people and you saw that so
he said this is a great economic that
everybody everything it's always about
money these wars are always about these
are economic Wars the thing with China
is economic War the thing with Ukraine
as an economic War Libya was an economic
War he was trying to come he was trying
to create a currency for Africa you know
that and so anyway go ahead we have a
reporter a lot aliyahu I think he was
the one telling us about this because
he's gone down to cover a lot of these
Pro Ukraine events yeah and he says
these people will wave the azov flag
they will wave overt Nazi symbols it's
not it's not like the women swastikas or
anything but there's comparable related
symbols that they will wave around and
they don't care
and where's antifa and these leftist
organizations who oppose this to come
out for some reason no idea and I'll
tell you this the funny thing
antifa is an interesting thing it's an
idea right it's a whatever it is these
people whatever whatever they're
fighting I'll tell you they're not
fighting as Pro as of pro-nazi
protesters but they have beaten up guys
who opposed restrictions and lockdowns
and they have shown up to attack people
who are holding a free speech event in
DC they were having an anti-big Tech
censorship rally so you have protesters
opposing corporate power multinational
corporations antifa shows up and attacks
people you had a small handful of people
outside of a hospital protesting the
lockdown measures they had put in place
antifa shows up and starts beating up
people then you have pro-azov protesters
celebrating this Nazi group and they're
nowhere to be found makes you wonder
about their real uh real goals and if
it's even real antifa could be a false
flag someone's like I'm antifa let's do
some damage but they they claim that
they say anyone can be so that's on them
that's that's their idea whatever I see
antifa doing anything I just think
they're all
useful idiots and feds yeah I don't yeah
there was a story about some antifa guy
who gets arrested you know they grab
them they put them in a car they drive
them around and drop them off and
everyone's like how how dare you arrest
this guy and I'm like oh yes how how
strange that he got picked up by the
cops they drove him around then dropped
him off again that's what they do with
their informants that's right I want to
talk to him in the car I say what's
going on and then drop them off this is
my thing with the liberal economic order
and the military-industrial complex at
first I didn't know what it was and then
in 2007 I got red pilled and I was like
oh God oh God that's the enemy and now
I'm looking at the five of the six most
valuable weapons manufacturers on Earth
you know Lockheed Martin Boeing Etc the
list goes on are American companies so
if if we didn't have the military
industrial complex in America and it was
in another country like China we'd all
be communist slaves so maybe it's a good
thing that the military-industrial
complex is there I'm having this
existential crisis like Jimmy's face
there's gonna be a military industrial
complex on Earth whether or not we
control or have some influence over it I
think it's important that we do
otherwise
it's complete take the microchip but we
don't have any they they are the ones
right they're the they're the Puppet
Masters and we're the puppets so they're
the ones that why do why are we in Iraq
same same reason why are we in Libya
same reason Afghanistan Syria Ukraine
Sudan Somalia Yemen same thing it's all
the same reason and so there's there's
that book uh uh more is a racket by
Smedley muddler I mean he talked about
this in the 30s there's that there's
that book called um confessions of an
economic Hitman so whenever you see a
marine somewhere uh you would best
believe we're there to at the behest of
a capitalist or a corporation American
corporation and we're there to steal
natural resources so if if this is true
what we're just talking about which I
think it is because that's what we do is
speak the truth um what's like what's a
good solution moving forward because if
we get rid of the military-industrial
complex it will create a void that will
be filled by some corporation uh foreign
natural resources but uh don't those
natural resources make our lives better
well there's that I mean it's true look
you're asking
um well it's like like everybody admits
that we stole the land from the Native
Americans you know and I'm like and I
feel bad about it but I ain't giving it
back because it's really nice here
that's what I used to say in my ACT it's
nice yeah it is um you know look I'm
watching Yellowstone and you have you
watched that at all no what is it it's a
it's a big hit show on the Paramount
Network it's about this family a Seventh
Generation Ranch in Montana they own I
think it was like 2 million Acres or
something massive yeah they're the
largest private landowners in Montana
yeah and so everybody wants their land
and you know the Native American
reservation says it's our land you just
shut up one day and took it and we want
it back the way it used to be and uh
it's fascinating because that is the an
ideology that's growing of like
reversing conquest and no like certainly
we can be more charitable more Equitable
in the in the literal sense and and you
know enhance civil rights and things
like that and give people opportunity
but to like just
dismantle Your Existence in your country
because of a couple hundred years ago
makes no sense I can understand why War
today to steal resources is a bad thing
my view on this is I don't want your
resources I don't want the oil from Iraq
I don't care I would rather work in my
backyard work hard and take care of
animals and have to live a normal life
then be part of a machine that bombs
kids so that we can have cheap computers
yeah I'm with you that's just me that's
just me but there's a lot of people who
are going to say this dude they're going
to say I don't care because I I have
friends who are activists and they got
their MacBooks and I'm like you do
realize that people are walking off of
buildings in mass suicide in the
factories that that has them as slaves
to produce that and they're like well
I'm more effective this way and I'm like
I get it I get it I get it but if the
military industrial complex wasn't
parasiting off the brain of the liberal
economic order the British the French
the Americans then they would go
somewhere else and parasite off the
brains of another country I would
imagine and then just bomb us instead so
um
I think that this is what Eisenhower
warned us against is the undue influence
of the military-industrial complex and
it's been the last 40 Years of our
foreign policy has been dictated by them
so I think it's possible to get control
of them
um other countries have control of their
military we don't so I I and that's what
this rally is about on Sunday at the
Lincoln Memorial uh is about us people
rising up and getting control of our
military-industrial complex again and
getting control of our government again
and we got to start somewhere and
there's been no anti-war movement in
this country for the last 20 years so I
think it's time to start one and I think
this Sunday is a good chance to do it
and I think if we don't do it uh our
Empire is over right Americans we are an
Empire and we are ending the way all
Empires end we have a thousand military
they just built three more military
bases in Philippines they just announced
it so while we have people living under
every bridge it's unbelievable we have
every we have and the bridges are
falling down on top of them right we
always fix our freaking Bridges how come
we didn't get a couple hundred years of
Empire like the Romans did or there was
prosperity for a little bit but you
lived under a boot right we might the
Republic fell and then you know the type
things happen faster things change
quicker so for better or worse and the
petrol dollars going away right so
that's another thing about Ukraine is
that it's screwing up the petrol dollar
and people don't know how important it
is now the reason why we're in Yemen
helping commit a genocide while we wag
our finger at Putin for invading Ukraine
that's a good one is and by the way
we're we're occupying a third of Syria
right now the United States military is
occupying a third of Syria illegally and
which third is it the third with the oil
why do you think and how do I know we're
doing that because the president of the
United States said we were is this is
world war three I mean look people look
yes it could be very easily people look
at Ukraine and they're like Russia you
know Russia is going to start World War
Three and it's like I don't know maybe
our invasions of Iraq Afghanistan are
our military incursions into Syria the
Arabs spring Libya I mean we destroyed
that whole country we're terrorists I
mean America is the terrorists I'm gonna
say this I believe in America and I
believe we've been taken over by
terrorists who have used the corporate
media and and institutions to lull
people to sleep or convince them that
it's good that they're doing these
things yes
I love playing civilization Ian would
understand this one I might go over your
head you ever play Civilization no it's
a game where you build a civilization
it's that simple develop technology I'll
tell you how I play when I got my little
country I developed weapons technology I
make a very robust military and I'm on
my own business I I say here's where I'm
at I'm doing my thing don't with me
we'll swear a little bit we already
swore so we're swearing now and uh then
in the game when people come to my
borders and start talking I crush
them but I mind my own business
problem is when the Spanish Empire
builds a military Outpost in Cuba right
off your border and you're like whoa now
they're putting nukes in Cuba so
remember what we did when they were
trying to put nukes in Cuba we we almost
had a World War III well that's the
equivalent of what we're doing in
Ukraine right now what's NATO's doing
and people are always like oh Putin's a
Madman no Putin is a rational actor and
we all knew this was going to happen and
this was provoked that's what the people
don't realize the United States provoked
this Invasion how did they do that well
they ramped up the bombing of the
donbass double in the months just
leading up to it the Minsk agreement uh
Angela Merkel the former uh prime
minister of Germany just admitted that
the only reason they had that peace
agreement was so Ukraine could buy time
to build up their military getting ready
for this Invasion from and that they
knew they were going to provoke didn't
didn't Boris Johnson like fly there to
stop to stop the peace I said they had a
peace agreement in last March and Boris
Johnson at the NATO Aaron boy flew there
and said you can't do this or you know
you're going to get killed and that was
that I think this is why we had to sell
it to Americans so intensely right of
course you had to have your flags out
you had to believe it because history
had to start with Putin started this and
Russia gate was the thing we all said
Aaron mate had said this on my show Max
Blumenthal I said that Russia gate was
was setting the groundwork for war and
that's exactly what has happened so now
people are Al gung-ho for going to war
against Russia over Ukraine thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time